-Hi, everyone.
I'm Sarah Jenks-Daly,
supervising producer
at "Late Night"
and this is "Late Night Lit."
♪♪
You may know Adrienne Brodeur
from her past work,
in particular,
her best-selling memoir,
"Wild Game," which was published
a few years ago.
Her latest is a novel
called "Little Monsters,"
which is set on Cape Cod
and is a spectacular
reading choice
for wherever you find
yourself this summer.
We're joined by Adrienne to talk
about what surprised her
when writing a story
from multiple perspectives,
her work as
the executive director
of the literary
nonprofit Aspen Words.
And if her two teenagers
ever weigh in
with what they think
of her books.
Now, here's my chat
with Adrienne Brodeur.
Today, we are joined
by the author
of the new novel
"Little Monsters."
Adrian, thanks for being here
on "Late Night Lit."
-Thanks for having me, Sarah.
-This novel is terrific.
I really enjoyed it.
It's a story about a family
living on Cape Cod,
which is actually where
you are now. Is that right?
-Actually, I'm in Cambridge
right now,
but I do live on Cambridge
and Cape Cod.
I split my time.
-Okay.
So the tourist season
is upon you
or approaching out there.
I wondered, have you thought
about how surreal
this might be
to walk down the beach
and see someone reading
your book this summer?
-I would love
to walk down a beach
and see someone reading
my book ever.
I've actually never impromptu
stumbled upon someone
reading a work of mine.
-I think that's more common
maybe if you live
in New York City
and you ride
the subway frequently,
or a place where you're running
into a lot of commuters.
-There you go.
I'll work on moving.
-I read that you were at least
partially inspired for the story
by a biblical tale when it came
to the idea
for "Little Monsters."
Can you tell us about that?
-Sure. Well, you know,
it's an interesting process
how any authors find
their way to their books.
But I noticed
what I was noticing,
which is basically my mind
or my subconscious
kept alighting on siblings
and sibling rivalry
and what made this
sort of relationship
so fraught often
and so ripe for --
for delving into and exploring.
And in any case, I thought then
I should go to the original
sibling-rivalry tale
of Cain and Abel.
And of course, I got there
and that is the slimmest,
most bare-bones story on earth.
I pretty much
got nothing from it.
I was waiting for, you know,
well, why did, why did.
But actually, in the end,
what I took away
from Cain and Abel
without even
really realizing it,
which I'm so grateful for,
was the structure of the book,
the idea that gifts
would be given
and this would be a way
to reveal a favoritism
or a perceived favoritism.
So the momentum
of "Little Monsters"
all works towards this event
at the summer when
the patriarch is turned 70.
It's his birthday celebration.
-There are varying
perspectives in the book
you write from.
I think --
Is it five different char--?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay, so Abby and Ken,
the siblings you spoke about,
their father, Adam,
Steph, who readers will learn
who she is,
and Jenny, who is Ken's wife.
Was there one perspective
that you were either drawn to
that was easy for you
to write or alternately
really difficult for you
to find the headspace for?
-I love this question
because I feel like
I've got the weirdest answer,
which is that Adam,
the 70-year-old bipolar
patriarch, just came to me.
I would literally put my hands
over the keyboard
and he just he arrived
on the page, fully formed,
sort of this cantankerous,
funny, brilliant,
you know, dysfunctional,
wonderful guy.
And he just spoke to me.
With all the rest
of the characters,
I mean, they were of varying
difficulty at different moments,
but it was much more
the traditional you have
to write sort of halfway
into your novel
to sort of get
to know them well enough
to really have them
kind of come easily to you.
But it was so fun to be
in a very close
third-person point of view
for each of them to be really
deep in their heads
simply because it was kind of
this kaleidoscopic look
at this family.
-Well, that's interesting
because I was struck
by how each perspective
was specific,
incredibly specific,
and also felt consistent
to the character
and the voice as I was reading
and when I finished.
So but I guess that might
have taken some time for you
if that's something
you realize halfway through.
But how did you try to ensure
that each voice did sound
unique enough to you?
-Really, it is like
getting to know them.
I mean, I think
there's this thought
that you approach
a novel kind of with this --
I mean, you do have
a formed idea,
but it's this --
it's this combination
of having to hold tight
to what you know
and not so -- not so tightly
that a lot of stuff,
a lot of unexpected things
can't happen.
So it is just what you said.
It is the process
of going for some time,
getting to know
these characters very well.
But the fun about
being so deeply
inside the various points
of view is that
your reader knows more than
any of the other characters do.
So you've sort of got this very
rich environment to play with.
-Your previous book
was an award-winning memoir
called "Wild Game."
I haven't read that yet.
I just want to start off.
I definitely will
now that I've read about it.
I'd guess that that was
a completely different
writing experience
than a fictional story.
But there are some similarities
from what I read
in terms of the setting
and maybe honesty
in relationships
and the secrets that people
keep that you seem like
you want to continue to explore.
And I was wondering
if that is true.
Is that something you find you
want to keep writing about?
-Absolutely.
I think -- I mean,
as anyone
who has read "Wild Game,"
I mean, it just will come
as no surprise
that I'm fascinated
by family secrets and that,
you know, they inhabit
this new book in a big way.
And I just think
secret keeping -- it's so --
I mean, "A,"
it's something that most humans
do on some level or another.
And it just makes for really
compelling fiction or nonfiction
for that matter, because there's
a tension between the truth,
between what's making you
keep these secrets.
Is it shame?
Is it being kind?
Why are you holding
this information?
And of course, the, "Uh-oh, when
is it gonna come out?"
Which we all know,
you know, secrets --
secrets don't like
to stay secret.
-And sometimes they don't
come out
at the best times either.
-Absolutely.
-I was wondering what
the writing process
in general looks like for you.
Do you try to set specific time
aside in your day to do it?
-Yes, I am one
of those discipline writers.
I do not wait
for the muse to strike.
I sit down and hope
she can keep up.
But yeah, I, you know,
I have two children.
I've got an elderly father.
I have a job that I love.
I've got a very busy life
like most of us.
And so I carve time
when no one can bother me,
which I have found
the perfect time is 5:00 a.m.
No one -- It's before my own
to-do list can kick in.
So I just, I get my coffee,
I sit at my desk,
I either write longhand
or on my computer.
But it's really just sort
of the witching hour.
It's the perfect hour for me.
It's -- it's quiet.
It's that liminal state.
I think I'm still connected
to my subconscious a bit,
but it's -- it's perfect.
And that's when
I write every day.
-Do you find you have to do it
in the same place?
-No. I mean, I really can write
almost anywhere provided,
but I'm not good --
I admire the people
who can go to Starbucks
and have music
in the background and so on.
I have my little weird,
quirky writer rituals
and have to kind of
just feel right.
But then I can
I can do it anywhere.
-You mentioned
your two children.
Do they read anything you write
or are they interested?
-Well, you know, my daughter
has read this novel,
which was really fun because
she hadn't read the memoir,
which was fine.
In fact,
I sort of felt proud of the fact
that she didn't read it,
because I had been,
as you'll know,
if you read the memoir,
I had been so obsessed
and overly involved
with my own mother
that I thought,
"Wow, this is great.
She doesn't want to know
every nuance of my personal
life, and that's fabulous."
And she loves
really worldbuilding fiction
and those types of things,
but she read it on spring break
and really loved it,
which was fun.
My son is 14 and I'd say,
"No, he's not so interested."
My father was a writer
and I didn't read his work
until I was in my early 20s.
I mean, I dipped in.
But, you know, snooze, right?
You're not interested
in your parents.
You're interested
in your social life.
-Yeah.
I don't think you're interested
in your parents
until you get older.
-Yeah.
-But that's probably
for the best, like you said.
-Definitely.
-In addition
to published author,
you're also -- you mentioned
a full-time job.
You're the executive director
of the literary nonprofit
Aspen Words.
I was hoping you
could talk a little bit
about what that role entails
and maybe some things
about the organization itself.
-I would love to.
So my background,
I sort of went through life
as a literary editor,
and then about 10 years ago,
I pivoted, which was wonderful,
into this role
as an executive director
of a literary nonprofit.
So Aspen Words is the literary
program of the Aspen Institute.
We have events
and a writing workshop.
We have
an author-speaking series.
We have writing.
We have a writer
in residency program.
And one exciting program we do,
which I started about
5 or 6 years ago,
is the Aspen Words
Literary Prize,
which is a $35,000 award
for a work of fiction
that shines a spotlight
on a social issue.
But it's really
just a fantastic organization
whose mission
is to inspire readers,
encourage writers, and connect
people through stories.
-That's fantastic.
I hope people get a chance
to check that out,
as well as your novel,
which is so great.
Lastly, I wanted to ask,
is there a book you'd like
to recommend for our listeners
to pick up this summer?
-I just finished
Claire Dederer's "Monsters,"
and it is such a brilliant book.
It is nonfiction
and it's essentially
this really thoughtful
reflection
on what to do
with famous artists
who are also
monstrous people.
So like the Picassos
of the world,
the Roman Polanskis,
but she is just so reflective
and so thoughtful
about how she approaches it.
And it's something I think
we're all thinking about.
-Absolutely.
-That sounds fascinating.
I'll have to check
that out, too.
-She's a great writer.
-Well, thank you again,
Adrienne.
It was so nice to talk to you
and thank you for taking
the time to join us.
-Thank you.
-This has been "Late Night Lit."
My thanks to Seth Meyers,
Mike Shoemaker,
Adrienne Brodeur,
Jay Johnson, Ross Leupold,
Maria Torres
and Raphael Aguilos.
Our theme music was written
and performed
by the 8G band.
For "Late Night
with Seth Meyers,"
I'm Sarah Jenks-Daly.
Thanks for listening
and happy reading.